yeah welcome to this video playing lead
and stina at that played this before I
played him before we had this apparent
Carol calm and we had this rule Oh pass
exchange to know we get a pretty weird
line of the calc on where it seems like
I'm just a temple up compared to two
other lines this is really weird what is
he doing here open it looks like black
is really a an excellent shape here with
the porn how does he protect it even I
just threatened to take it after Bishop
f4 or something I just take it we not a
force not not so great now i can i can
take but it's that some compensation
might be five or something maybe but
still come on this is this is a rather
big set of all you need to take it might
be five I can I can I can I can okay he
just doesn't do it Jim you should be six
shouldn't be too bad setting up a
possible discovery and its are
developing a piece okay all this guy is
playing some weird stuff
mmm yeah the hope he wants to take on a
sick show yeah maybe if I castle he
takes on f6 and takes on d5 technical
tactical trickier hmm I seem okay
keelung castles you can take F 6585
Bishop g4 wins the Queen this is cute
actually nice trick okay so something
else somehow this is a bit a bit shaky
hmm
I should fall asleep you need to play
something stupid okay let's just prevent
the doubling of pawns shouldn't be
shouldn't be too bad ok and now castles
come on castles I want to get liking out
of the middle as I saw that he can take
on d5 but I wanted to wanted to develop
ok and I thought I could take on between
but maybe Ruby oneness would be one to
be seven this too much of a nuisance
yeah this wasn't i wasn't too great I
need to take it anyway rupee 7i can also
go to a four or anything it's not not
something to too dramatic
check hmm maybe you can take f7 this is
really sick but maybe you can ruger
seven Luke f7 Bishop aah yep King I can
play I can take it can take h7 only
weird okay why are attacking a 2 and c2
so maybe needs to attend to this first
this can be one of those positions where
the bishop is on f3 and it if the rock
moves away from a age this Bishop can be
a rather rather bad piece even because
it doesn't attack anything maybe you can
take F sub ma'am I don't really see a
reputation okay what's the idea h4 maybe
yeah well anyway I grab c2h4 I can
always play Queen here Queen a form it's
this maybe I should have considered this
a bit longer
hmm at the end he can move the rook end
I'm pulling up but it's a it's not to
grade
yeah at the end he might move the rock
anthem and my book my book is subject
and you win da porn this can be a
problem however looking for strange I'm
not sure what is playing now the rook
moves away from the hub play Queenie one
Queen e5 and get rid of the Queen's
under rather favorable circumstances
what what the heck is this I don't
understand what Quincy 7 or what is the
big big thing no it's not working I
don't understand what he's doing not at
all ah Queenie one Queen e5 he can he
can take on nanos is not a check yeah
and this is simply nonsense I can I can
do that check
nine blundering g6 Oh God yeah from that
position what a shame I'm warning ya
real shame I mean this is was just a
joke of a game I mean and I just
blundered it away Jack
check-check
one of those days check check check
check
Jack yeah of course you can resign
before because you will never make the
time control ah what a nonsensical game
I really I really saw some goes to him I
thought he had some some kind of idea
but of course it was all nonsense and I
could just take everything yeah and this
is of course just winning but it's a
it's tricky I'm not sure why I don't see
the time really would be interesting to
see the time for some reason it is not
displayed no idea yeah okay it makes no
sense to analyze because it was winning
all along but I just didn't make her
make the time control of course this was
just terrible so just whatever I mean f4
yeah okay this isn't isn't so easy he's
rather active may be here somewhere ya
ali to be a bit more precise but ok it's
impossible to do with a couple of
seconds for whatever the reason the
seconds are not displayed and I also
could have played this one which is even
more decisive ok yeah thanks for
watching